una conversación a la vez.
Y la pregunta es, ¿qué te gustaría recordar
si tuvieras tan solo 45 minutos con tu abuela?
Lo que es interesante, en las conversaciones con el fundador, Dave Isay,
en realidad siempre hablamos de esto
un poco como un proyecto subversivo,
porque cuando lo piensas,
en realidad no es realmente acerca de las historias que se cuentan,
es acerca de escuchar
y es acerca de las preguntas que puedes hacer,
preguntas que no tenías permiso para hacer
en otra época.
Voy a reproducir solo un par de pasajes rápidos del proyecto.
[Jesús Meléndez habla de los últimos momentos del poeta Pedro Pietri]
Jesús Meléndez: Salimos y como estábamos ascendiendo,
antes de habernos estabilizado,
nuestro punto de nivel inicial era de 14 km
entonces antes de habernos estabilizado,
Pedro empezó a dejarnos,
y la belleza de esto
es que creo que hay algo después de la vida.
Lo puedes ver en Pedro.
[Danny Perasa a su esposa Annie Perasa con quien estuvo casado 26 años]
Danny Perasa: Mira, la cosa es que
siempre me siento culpable cuando te digo "Te amo",
y lo digo con tanta frecuencia. Lo digo para recordarte
que, lleno de defectos como soy, viene desde mí,
es como escuchar una canción hermosa de una vieja radio rota,
y es agradable de tu parte mantener la radio en la casa.
(Risas)
[Michael Wolmetz con su novia Debora Brakarz]
Michael Wolmetz: Este es el anillo que mi padre le dio a mi madre,
y podemos dejarlo ahí.
Y ahorró y lo compró
y le propuso matrimonio a mi madre con él,
y entonces pensé que iba a dártelo a ti
para que pudiera estar con nosotros para esto también.
Así que voy a compartir el micrófono contigo en este momento, Débora.
¿Dónde está el dedo derecho?
Debora Brakarz: (Llorando)
MW: Debora, ¿te casarías conmigo?
DB: Sí. Por supuesto. Te amo.
(Besos)
MW: Niños, así es como su madre y yo nos casamos,
en un stand en la estación Grand Central, con el anillo de mi padre.
Mi abuelo fue taxista por 40 años.
Recogía gente aquí todos los días.
Por lo que parece apropiado.
Jake Barton: Debo decir
que en realidad no elegí estas muestras individuales para hacerlos llorar
porque todos los hacen llorar.
Todo el proyecto se basa en este acto de amor
que es escuchar en sí mismo.
Y el movimiento de construir una institución
de un momento de conversar y escuchar
tiene que ver mucho con lo que mi firma, Local Projects,
está haciendo con nuestros compromisos en general.
Así que somos una empresa de diseño de medios de comunicación y estamos trabajando
con una amplia gama de diferentes instituciones
construyendo instalaciones de medios de comunicación para museos y espacios públicos.
Nuestro último trabajo es el Museo de Arte de Cleveland,
para el que hemos creado un trabajo llamado Galería Uno.
Y Galería Uno es un proyecto interesante
porque comenzó con esta masiva expansión de $350 millones
para el Museo de Arte de Cleveland
y en realidad llevamos esta pieza
específicamente para cultivar nuevas capacidades, nuevas audiencias,
al mismo tiempo que el propio museo está creciendo.
Glenn Lowry, director del MoMA, lo expresó mejor cuando dijo:
"Queremos que los visitantes dejen de ser visitantes.
Los visitantes son transitorios. Queremos a la gente que vive aquí,
personas que tienen la propiedad".
Así que lo que estamos haciendo es hacer un arreglo amplio
de diferentes maneras para que la gente participe efectivamente
con el material en el interior de estas galerías,
por lo que aún puedes tener una experiencia tradicional de galería,
pero si estás interesado, puedes participar
con cualquier obra de arte individual y ver el contexto original
de dónde viene, o manipular la propia obra.
Entonces, por ejemplo, puedes hacer click en esta cabeza individual de león,
y aquí es donde se originó, 1300 a. C.
O esta pieza individual aquí,
puedes ver el dormitorio real. Realmente cambia el modo
en que piensas acerca de este tipo de pinturas al temple.
Esta es una de mis favoritas porque se ve el propio estudio.
Este es el busto de Rodin. Uno tiene la sensación
de esta increíble fábrica de creatividad.
Y que te hace literalmente pensar en los cientos,
o miles de años de la creatividad humana y la forma
en que cada obra de arte individual representa una parte de esa historia.
Este es Picasso,
que por supuesto representa mucho de lo que es el siglo XX.
La próxima interfaz, que voy a mostrar,
aprovecha la idea de este linaje de creatividad.
Es un algoritmo que te permite navegar
la colección vigente del museo utilizando el reconocimiento facial.
Esta persona está haciendo diferentes caras,
y dibujando sucesivamente diferentes objetos
de la colección que se conectan con exactamente lo que está buscando.
Y así te puedes imaginar que, mientras las personas se están presentando
dentro del propio museo, recibes este sentido
de esta conexión emocional,
la forma en que nuestro rostro se conecta con los miles
y decenas de miles de años.
Se trata de una interfaz que realmente te permite dibujar
y luego dibuja sucesivamente objetos usando las mismas formas.
Así que cada vez más estamos tratando de encontrar la manera
de que la gente en realidad sea un autor dentro de los museos,
de que sean creativos aunque estén viendo
la creatividad de otras personas y entendiéndolos
Así que en este muro, el muro de las colecciones,
pueden ver todas las 3000 obras de arte, todas al mismo tiempo,
y pueden realizar sus propios
paseos individuales por el museo, y pueden compartirlos,
y alguien puede hacer un recorrido con el director del museo
o una excursión con un primo.
Pero todo el tiempo que hemos estado trabajando
en este trabajo con Cleveland,
también hemos estado trabajando en el fondo
en nuestro mayor trabajo hasta la fecha,
el Monumento y Museo sobre el 11-S.
Comenzamos en el 2006
como parte de un equipo con Thinc Design
para crear el plan maestro original para el museo,
y hemos hecho todo el diseño de medios
tanto para el museo y el monumento y luego la producción de medios.
El monumento se inauguró en 2011,
y el museo va a abrir el próximo año, en el 2014.
Y como pueden ver en estas imágenes,
el sitio es tan puro y casi arqueológico.
Y por supuesto el evento en sí es tan reciente,
en algún lugar entre la historia y los acontecimientos actuales,
que fue un gran desafío imaginar
cómo se sobrevive realmente hasta un espacio como este,
un evento como éste, para contar esa historia.
Entonces comenzamos con
una nueva forma de pensar acerca de construir una institución,
a través de un proyecto llamado Hagamos Historia,
que lanzamos en 2009.
Estimamos que un tercio del mundo
vio el 11-S en vivo,
un tercio del mundo
escuchó sobre él durante 24 horas,
con total naturalidad lo que sucedió durante
este momento sin precedentes de conciencia global.
Así que lanzamos esto para capturar las historias
de todo el mundo,
a través de video, a través de fotos,
a través de la historia escrita,
y así las experiencias de las personas en ese día,
que era, de hecho, este enorme riesgo para la institución
hacer su primer movimiento de esta plataforma abierta.
Pero eso se acopló con esta cabina de historias orales,
realmente lo más simple que hemos hecho,
donde te encuentras a ti mismo en un mapa.
Está en seis idiomas y puedes contar tu propia historia
sobre lo que te pasó en ese día.
Y cuando empezamos a ver las increíbles imágenes
y las historias que llegaron
de todo el mundo,
esto es obviamente parte del tren de aterrizaje,
realmente comenzamos a entender
que había una increíble simetría
entre el evento,
entre la forma en que la gente estaba contando las historias sobre el evento,
y la forma en que nosotros necesitábamos contar esa historia.
Esta imagen en particular, realmente capturó
nuestra atención en ese momento,
porque resume ese evento.
Esta es una foto del túnel Brooklyn-Battery.
Hay un carro de bomberos atrapado en el tráfico,
y los bomberos están corriendo
2 km y medio hasta el sitio
con más de 30 kg de equipo en su espalda.
Y tenemos este increíble correo electrónico que decía:
"Al ver las miles de fotos en el sitio,
inesperadamente encontré una foto de mi hijo.
Fue un shock emocional, pero una bendición encontrar esta foto",
y estaba escribiendo porque,
"Me gustaría agradecer personalmente al fotógrafo
por publicar la foto,
ya que significa más de lo que las palabras pueden describirme
para tener acceso a lo que es probablemente
la última foto tomada de mi hijo".
Y la verdad es que nos hace reconocer
lo que esta institución necesitaba hacer
para contar realmente la historia.
No podemos tener solo un historiador o un curador
que narre objetivamente en tercera persona acerca de un evento así,
cuando existen los testigos de la historia
que van a hacer su camino
a través del museo en sí.
Entonces comenzamos a imaginar el museo,
junto con el equipo creativo del museo y los curadores,
pensando en cómo la primera voz que se oye
dentro del museo sería en realidad la de otros visitantes.
Y por eso hemos creado esta idea de una galería abierta
que llamamos Recordamos.
Voy a reproducirles una parte de una maqueta de la misma,
pero les dará una idea de lo que se siente al entrar
en ese momento en el tiempo
y ser transportado hacia atrás en la historia.
(Video) Voz 1: Estaba en Honolulu, Hawái. Voz 2: Estaba en El Cairo, Egipto.
Voz 3: Al sur de los Campos Elíseos, en París. Voz 4: En la universidad, en U.C. Berkeley.
Voz 5: Estaba en Times Square. Voz 6: São Paulo, Brasil.
(Voces múltiples)
Voz 7: Fue probablemente alrededor de las 11 de la noche.
Voz 8: Estaba conduciendo al trabajo a la hora local 5:45 de la mañana.
Voz 9: En realidad estábamos en una reunión
cuando alguien irrumpió y dijo:
"Oh, Dios mío, un avión se ha estrellado contra el World Trade Center".
Voz 10: Tratando de conseguir desesperadamente un radio.
Voz 11: Cuando lo escuché por la radio...
Voz 12: Lo escuché en la radio.
(Voces múltiples)
Voz 13: Recibí una llamada de mi padre. Voz 14: El teléfono sonó, me despertó.
Mi compañero de trabajo me dijo que encendiera la televisión.
Voz 15: Así que encendí la televisión.
Voz 16: Todos los canales en Italia mostraban lo mismo.
Voz 17: Las Torres Gemelas. Voz 18: Las Torres Gemelas.
JB: Y te mueves a partir de ahí
a ese cavernoso espacio abierto.
Este es el llamado muro pantalla.
Es la pared excavada en la base original del World Trade Center
que resistió la presión del río Hudson
durante un año completo después del evento.
Entonces pensamos en llevar esa sensación de autenticidad,
de la presencia de ese momento
en la exposición en sí.
Y contamos las historias de estar dentro de las torres
a través de ese mismo collage de audio,
lo que están escuchando, son literalmente personas hablando sobre
ver a los aviones estrellándose en el edificio,
o bajando por las escaleras.
Y conforme haces el camino en la exposición
donde se habla de la recuperación,
realmente proyectamos directamente en esos momentos
de acero trenzado, todas las experiencias de la gente
que literalmente escarbaban en la parte superior de la pila.
Y para que puedan escuchar historias orales,
las personas que estaban realmente trabajando en las llamadas brigadas de cubo
mientras están viendo, literalmente, miles de experiencias
de ese momento.
Y al salir de ese momento de narración
comprendiendo sobre el 11-S,
regresamos al museo de nuevo a un momento de escucha
y a hablar con los visitantes individuales
y pedirles sus propias experiencias sobre el 11-S.
Y les hacemos preguntas que en realidad no son
realmente contestables, los tipos de preguntas
que el 11-S en sí atrae sucesivamente para todos nosotros.
Y así, se trata de cuestiones como,
"¿Cómo puede la democracia balancear la libertad y la seguridad?"
"¿Cómo puede haber sucedido el 11-S?"
"¿Y cómo cambió el mundo después del 11-S?"
Y así estas historias orales,
que hemos estado capturando ya desde hace años,
se mezclan luego junto con entrevistas
que estamos haciendo con gente como Donald Rumsfeld,
Bill Clinton, Rudy Giuliani,
y se mezclan juntos estos diferentes actores
y estas experiencias diferentes,
estos diferentes puntos de reflexión sobre el 11-S.
Y de pronto la institución, una vez más,
se convierte en una experiencia de sonido.
Así que Ies reproduciré un breve extracto
de una maqueta que hicimos de un par de estas voces,
pero realmente tendrán una sensación
de la poesía de la reflexión de todos en el evento.
(Video) Voz 1: El 11-S no fue solo una experiencia de Nueva York.
Voz 2: Es algo que compartimos, y es algo que nos unía.
Voz 3: Y supe cuando vi que,
las personas que estaban allí ese día de inmediato
fueron a ayudar a la gente conocida y desconocida para ellos
fue algo que nos haría salir adelante.
Voz 4: Toda la efusión de afecto y emoción
que venía de nuestro país era algo realmente
que para siempre se quedará conmigo.
Voz 5: Todavía hoy rezo y pienso en los
que perdieron la vida,
y aquellos que dieron su vida por salvar a otros,
pero también me recuerda a la estructura de este país,
el amor, la compasión, la fuerza,
y vi a una nación unida
en el medio de una terrible tragedia.
JB: Y mientras la gente sale del museo,
reflexionando sobre la experiencia, reflexionando sobre sus propios pensamientos sobre la misma,
se mueven en el espacio actual de la propia memoria,
porque han regresado,
y de hecho nos involucramos en el monumento
después de haber hecho el museo durante unos años.
El diseñador original del monumento, Michael Arad,
tenía esta imagen en su mente de todos los nombres que aparecen
indiferenciados, casi al azar,
realmente una reflexión poética sobre la naturaleza
de un evento terrorista,
pero fue un gran desafío para las familias, para la fundación,
sin duda para los primeros en responder,
y había una negociación que salió
y se encontró una solución
para no crear en realidad un orden en términos cronológicos,
o en términos alfabéticos,
sino a través de lo que se llama adyacencia significativa.
Así que estos son los grupos de los nombres propios
que aparecen indiferenciados pero en realidad tienen un orden,
y nosotros, junto con Jer Thorp, creamos un algoritmo
para tomar grandes cantidades de datos
para realmente empezar a conectar entre sí todos estos nombres.
Así que esta es una imagen del algoritmo
con los nombres por privacidad codificados,
pero se puede ver que estos bloques de color
son en realidad los cuatro vuelos diferentes,
las dos diferentes torres, los primeros en actuar,
y en realidad se puede ver entre los diferentes pisos,
y luego las líneas verdes son las conexiones interpersonales
que fueron solicitadas por las propias familias.
Así que cuando van al monumento,
pueden ver realmente la organización global
en el interior de las propias piscinas individuales.
Pueden ver la forma en que la geografía del evento
se refleja en el interior del monumento,
y pueden buscar un nombre individual,
o en este caso un empleador, Cantor Fitzgerald,
y ver la manera en que todos esos nombres,
los cientos de nombres, en realidad están organizados
en el monumento en sí,
y usar eso para navegarlo.
Y lo más importante, cuando en realidad están en el sitio
del monumento, se puede ver las conexiones.
Pueden ver las relaciones entre los diferentes nombres propios.
Así que de repente este indiferenciado, anónimo
grupo de nombres se convierten en realidad como una vida individual.
En este caso, Harry Ramos,
quien era el jefe de operaciones de un banco de inversión,
que se detuvo a ayudar a Victor Wald en el piso 55 de la Torre Sur.
Y Ramos le dijo a Wald, según testigos,
"No te voy a dejar".
Y la viuda de Wald solicitó que sean listados uno al lado del otro.
Hace tres generaciones, tuvimos que conseguir realmente que la gente
saliera y capturar las historias de personas comunes.
Hoy, por supuesto, hay una cantidad sin precedentes de historias
para todos nosotros que están siendo capturadas para las generaciones futuras.
Y esta es nuestra esperanza, esa es la poesía que hay en el interior de cada una de nuestras historias.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)